bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle émission du 7-8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 9 juin une
actualité marquée par les 25 ans de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
l'établissement organisé pour l'occasion
de nombreux événements sur ses
différents sites avec notamment la
première édition du thé d'aix une
conférence dédiée à l'innovation
mustapha larbaoui est notre invité fil
rouge pour cette émission le futur ex
président de l'étoile sportive de
trappes quittera dans quelques jours son
poste après à 14 ans de service nous
évoquerons avec lui ses souvenirs de le
regard qu'ils portent sur l'avenir du
club
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale nous reviendrons sur la
préparation du bac
à quelques jours des premières épreuves
ou encore l'inauguration du skate park à
maurepas
mais on ouvre cette émission sur un
rassemblement ce vendredi matin à
montigny le bretonneux entre 200 et 300
salariés du groupe parapétrolier
saipem étaient présents devant les
locaux de leur entreprise pour protester
contre la suppression prévue de 2 151
postes sur les 1800 du site des
suppressions inscrite dans le cadre du
plan de sauvegarde de l'entreprise
écoutez à ce propos le représentant du
syndicat cfdt le dirigeant du groupe
reçoit les jeunes à la ferme du banney
aujourd'hui et parmi les jeunes une
partie d'entre eux vont être
moity censier demain donc on trouve ça
quand même un peu déplacé donc on a mis
à la profit ce jour pour pour ce pour
manifester on demande de revoir leur
copie on demande éventuellement un plan
de départs volontaires sur toute la
société
il ya des candidats et on ne veut pas de
suppression définitive de deux postes
contacté par la rédaction de tv fil 78
la direction de saipem france n'a pas
souhaité faire de commentaire dans le
reste de l'actualité un anniversaire et
les 25 ans de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
l'occasion pour le personnel les
étudiants et les anciens de se retrouver
lors d'une journée spéciale ce jeudi
au programme de nombreuses animations et
notamment le premier thé d'aix uv est ce
qu une conférence consacrée à
l'innovation c'était à versailles retour
sur cette première avec mélanie poquet
invisible mais essentiel déclinée en
différentes disciplines c'était le thème
du premier tedx uv est ce qu un projet
mené par quatre étudiants de l'institut
supérieur de management de l'université
à la base on voulait orienté sur tout ce
qui est mystérieux et en fait on s'est
rendu compte que ce qui était souvent
mystérieuses c'est ce qu'on voyait pas
donc l'invisible et donc on s'est dit
c'est vrai que dans l'enclos monsanto il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
essentiels mais qui reste invisible et
c'est une chance unique d'avoir
conférence qui pourrait nous permettre
de connaître ces choses invisibles
une conférence consacrée à l'innovation
18 minutes pour chacun des cinq
intervenants
une première pour un anniversaire celui
de l'université lu vs qu souffle ses 25
bougies
quand les premiers sont arrivés ici avec
des bancs il y avait des cerveaux bien
comment tout s'est monté les labos de
recherche
on est à la fois très jeune on a on est
toujours on a toujours une taille
humaine qui nous permet et bien de
réagir très rapidement
tout le monde se connaissent assez
important mais
de cinq ans eh bien on se projette aussi
maintenant vers l'avenir
pour cette année scolaire 2016-2017
l'université versailles saint quentin a
accueilli plus de 18000 étudiants du
sport à présent et de grands noms de la
pétanque était ce mercredi au club des
clayes-sous-bois le champion du monde
malgache n à nous licencier dans la
ville et son compatriote cobra qui est
également en équipe nationale ont
participé tous les deux au traditionnel
tournoi du club local les deux joueurs
se préparent en vue du masters de
pétanque prévu cet été on écoute leur
réaction au micro de michael et demi
d'euros je ne sais pas vraiment de
l'entraînement mais c'est seulement du
décrochage plus pour lancer quelques
boules pour se mettre à l'aise avec le
climat c'est par rapport aux cris
matelas comme vous mais qu'avant être
ici avant que d'arriver à la veille où
tout ça parce qu'après on va te fatiguer
ici on va préparer un projet pour faire
les nains sony est notre invité du jour
pour cette émission pratique peut être
la pétanque qui s'est en tout cas il
connaît bien le football puisqu'il
préside l'étoile sportive de trappes
depuis 14 ans mustapha larbaoui bonsoir
bonsoir la pétanque
du coup avant de parler de football est
ce que c'est votre truc et si oui est-ce
que vous tirez est-ce que vous pointez
nom très sincèrement c'est pas c'est pas
un sport que je pratique mais paru être
la rivière
un peu plus de temps jeu mais ça reste
un sport donc il faut le pratiquer avec
assiduité
oui alors vous n'êtes pas avec nous
évidemment pour parler de pétanque mais
plutôt de football puisque vous quitter
la présidence du club de trappes
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on peut encore vous
appelez président et si oui jusqu'à
quand juridiquement président
jusqu'au 24 juin prochain entre
juridiquement oui ce président du club
jusqu'à jusqu'à cette date
ça fait 14 ans précisément que vous êtes
à la tête de ce club
vous étiez arrivé à la fin d'un cycle
c'est pour cette raison que vous partez
c'est pour laisser on va dire la place
peut-être à quelqu'un avec des nouvelles
idées une nouvelle vision du foot
pourquoi vous partez en fait vous avez
vous avez tout dit j'ai toujours
considéré que prendre les rênes d'une
entreprise d'une entreprise humaine
quelle qu'elle soit associatif
entreprenariale ou même des mandats
électoraux
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il fallait pas
s'accrocher et qu'il fallait savoir
passer la main
donc ça fait maintenant deux ans que j'y
pense un an que je le construis que je
construis donc la sortie
et puis maintenant ouais je pense qu'il
est temps de laisser la main c'est
quelque chose qu'on construit d'ailleurs
on ne part pas comme ça il faut se
préparer
moi j'ai toujours pensé que président et
c'était à la fois être dans son
quotidien
parce qu'il faut constamment répondre
aux demandes et aux sollicitations du
jour et du quotidien mais c'est prévoir
donc c'est anticiper donc faut anticiper
quand on quand on gère ce type de
l'association ce type de structure c'est
y met
allez on va dire pour employer les
grands mots une philosophie un cap une
politique sportive
il faut donc toujours se projeter dans
l'avenir donc anticiper il faut aussi
anticiper sa sortie et la prévoir et
aujourd'hui quel est le sentiment qui
vous anime c'est de la tristesse de la
nostalgie le sentiment du devoir
accompli aussi peut-être
on va en parler du rôle social de ce
club à trappes quel est le sentiment qui
prédomine chez vous aujourd'hui les
sentiments vous venez d'évoquer tout de
suite tout de suite puisqu'on en parle
savez vous que tout de suite de la
tristesse parce que j'ai c'est une
partie de notre vie en train de me
rendre compte qu'effectivement ça va se
terminer
donc c'est il ya ce côté déjà
nostalgique et en même temps c'est
surtout la fierté d'avoir travaillé et
que des équipes des équipes qui depuis
14 ans ont été pour la plupart auprès de
moi qui ont travaillé donc à mes côtés
qui ont fait un travail admirable
donc là on est en train de faire le
bilan de 14 ans on parle de ma personne
mais en réalité c'est essentiellement
les trappistes qui m'ont fait confiance
les éducateurs les trappistes ce qu'ont
mis leurs enfants c'est un club de plus
de 1000 licenciés qui avait aussi avec
le temps et voilà aujourd'hui le club le
plus important je crois des yvelines
dans des yvelines en termes de en terme
de
je dirais de nombre mais en même temps
que des résultats sportifs que tout le
monde peut voir sur internet
toutes les équipes sont en ligue les
équipes une des équipes deux sont au
niveau alors on league
c'est donc la région mais pour les
équipes deux des équipes b elles sont
toutes au meilleur niveau du département
donc en termes de résultats et en termes
de nombre ça fait maintenant du club de
foot de trappes à un très très bel
espace pour apprendre le foot est plus
plus que le foot d'ailleurs puisqu'on a
on a aussi la transmission des valeurs
la transmission des valeurs ce sont des
mots comme ça comme mai mais dans la
réalité il se passe beaucoup de choses
et 200 dans des fier encore une fois
toute une équipe autour de moi on va
parler peut-être de vos souvenirs en
presque quinze ans et il doit y en avoir
forcément beaucoup c'est logique c'est
une question un peu un peu difficile à
laquelle il faut répondre mais si vous
deviez retenir un moment un événement un
fait marquant que ce soit peut-être une
victoire une défaite
une rencontre une satisfaction la quelle
serait-elle malheureusement j'ai pas de
dates d'événements de match précis ce
que je peux vous dire c'est tous les
week-ends sont ultra intense
on a l'impression d'être au zapping on a
l'impression d'être multiplex de canal+
il ya tellement d'équipés qui sont qui
sont sortis à l'extérieur ou sur les
terrains de trappes
il ya tellement de monde sur les routes
que on est en connexion permanente donc
c'est tous ces moments là c'est tous ses
week-ends un pense que l'on vit c'est
des joints ces des vestiaires avec des
matches gagnés des moments difficiles et
monter des monnaies paris mais voilà on
retient aussi
des moments difficiles des moments
difficiles mais qu on retient aussi dans
le cadre d'une solidarité dans le cadre
de l'union
on a pu avoir les uns avec les autres
c'est vraiment le cas c'est vraiment le
cas d'une famille quoi tout simplement
donc oui il ya eu des décès par exemple
et des accidents j'entends extra sportif
très récemment d'ailleurs très récemment
voilà un extra sportifs mais mais qu'ils
sont voilà qui sont des moments que l'on
vit que l'on vit intensément semble mes
14 ans si je dois les résumer c'est
quand même du bonheur il faut beaucoup
d'émissions pour résumer 14 ans imagine
heures c'est du bonheur c'est beaucoup
de choses donc c'est chronophage mais
c'est du bonheur certains ont fait part
ça si on n'aime pas les gens et qui on
travaille on fait pas ça si on n'aime
pas dans l'actif dans l'action et puis
vous savez beaucoup beaucoup de travail
votre parcours est plutôt original
puisque à la base vous le foot c'était
pas forcément une destinée s'était pas
tracé aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu un
passionné de football vous pouvez le
dire clairement vous avez appris à aimer
le football
alors j'ai toujours aimé le football
mais je me suis réellement rendu compte
dans l'exercice de la présidence et en
étant au quotidien avec les éducateurs
et tous ceux qui pratiquent le foot que
c'est pas c'est véritablement un art
c'est véritablement une science il ya un
vrai boulot qui est effectuée il ya
vraiment des connaissances alors ce
qu'on sait du foot c'est au travers des
interviews de quelques joueurs à la télé
de quelques semaines seulement du
football il ya beaucoup de ces chiffres
dans l'extra l'extra sportif mais la
réalité c'est que quand on commence à
rentrer dans le dos dans le vif du sujet
c'est à la fois de la stratégie c'est à
la fois de la tactique cdu c'est du
coaching
il ya une vraie science du football
voilà et ceux qui le pratiquent
ça ne croiront pas aujourd'hui vous le
ball s'est terminée où vous pourriez
revenir que ce soit rapide ou ailleurs
avec votre expérience désormais avec 14
ans de président alain pour moi c'est
terminé
j'ai des projets pour habitude de dire
que pour moi c'est ne faut jamais dire
jamais alors pour le coup faut jamais
dire jamais donc je le dirai quand même
concernant le foot mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que gégé a pris maintenant
j'ai 56 ans j'ai vraiment appris que
tout était pareil que techniquement les
choses étaient différentes
mais que c'est toujours pareil donc
voilà j'ai fait de l'associatif j'ai
fait de l'entreprise aujourd'hui un club
de foot on peut passer à autre chose
on peut passer à autre chose parce que
je considère qu'on peut faire plein de
choses
techniquement les choses sont
différentes on doit donc les appréhender
on doit travailler le sujet mais
globalement ça reste du travail visait
de visas vis arrêt du travail de
relationnel on va parler de votre avenir
une autre question peut-être le rapport
avec ce club et cette ville
j'imagine déjà votre réponse à ma
question est est ce que vous diriez 4 ap
avec le contexte que l'on connaît qu'il
soit bon ou mauvais le rôle du président
d'un club de foot à trappes est un peu
plus que sportif est ce qu'on a un rôle
à part c'est à dire surtout sociale
envers les envers les enfants envers les
familles on sait que c'est des milieux
souvent très défavorisé est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'être plus qu'un
qu'un président sportif d'être parce
qu'un président sociale alors pour le
pour le coup je dirais pas je dirais pas
parce que je suis président du club de
foot de trappes
c'est juste que c'est ma nature d'aller
au delà de la technicité au delà du foot
au delà de ce qu'on enseigne ouais moi
j'ai le sentiment qu'on a un vrai devoir
parce qu'on a quand même majoritairement
des enfants et c'est précieux c'est
précieux
c'est délicat il ya des choses qu'il
faut enseigner
donc je dirais pas spécifiquement à
trappes je pense que je me comporterai
de la même façon partout et dans tous
les domaines
est-ce qu'on peut être président de
football à trappes comment on peut
l'être partout
oui est ce que n'a pas volé qui peut
venir demain oui oui je casse a un rôle
particulier dans cette villa non non il
ya pour moi ya pas qu il n'y a rien de
particulier
encore une fois le football c'est de la
discipline la discipline une fois
qu'elle est bien comprise et admise qui
allait bien transmises c'est à dire que
les gens la comprennent c'est un art et
cet art là il est enseigné de la même
façon à trappes qu'ailleurs le rapport
dans la dans le respect dans le voilà
pour moi tout ça c'est des choses qu'on
peut par définition administrer la même
phase on attrape qu'ailleurs il n'y a
pas une spécificité pour moi de trappes
par contre tu rappes a effectivement son
son voile à son sas et sensibilité qu'on
perdra toutes les villes voilà comme on
peut avoir des villes de 30000 habitants
en bretagne dans le sud de la france
mais clermont pour moi en tous les cas
je me suis pas inscrit dans une
différenciation pour bien comprendre
quand même votre votre marque à vous on
va parler de votre votre académie vous
avez lancé il ya presque deux ans avec
du soutien scolaire gratuit
ça va perdurer ça c'est parti pour pour
continuer alors j'en suis plutôt fier
avec mes équipes encore une fois alors
c'est pas du soutien scolaire je le
précise c'est du renfort mac français je
suis d'ailleurs très contents
d'apprendre que la nouvelle majorité
commencent à rentrer un petit peu dans
ce type de discussions c'est à dire
faire en sorte que au collège et surtout
un cm2 puisqu'il s'agit du cm2 de faire
en sorte que le renfort soit fait en
maths et en français sur le cm2
un peu anticipé mais c'est surtout que
pour moi c'est juste une évidente c'est
à dire que ça doit correspondre aux
valeurs que l'on transmet et en même
temps on enseigne le sport pour que le
physique suive
j'ai envie que le cerveau suivent
également aujourd'hui vous vous quittez
un club de football en bonne santé son
avenir et et assurez vous n'êtes pas
inquiet non non non je suis pas inquiet
il est 13 ème seriez pas partie sinon
j'imagine serais pas parti à ce moment
là un choix partie probablement plus
tard mais j'ai attendu le moment où
c'était très apaisée très structuré où
il ya vraiment des hommes et des femmes
qui sont en place et pour moi il n'y a
aucune aucune difficulté en tout cas si
je pars c'est parce que c'est bien
construit et en même temps j'ai vraiment
envie de m'occuper de mes parents ont
priorité c'est vraiment le l'objectif
majeur
on dirait sardane willie deane par
contre on se doit de donner à ses
parents dans tous les cas moi c'est
quelque chose qui est important pour moi
et voilà et en même temps je remercie
tous ceux et celles qui ont travaillé
pour ses 14 magnifique et forcément vous
allez garder un regard particulier sur
les résultats du club j'imagine qu'on ne
quitte jamais vraiment un clown un nom
bien sûr là c'est l'affect qui va
continuer à manille mais bien sûr je
vais regarder trappe plutôt qu'un canot
de club mais voilà avec une séance c'est
avec une distance bien évidemment puis
après il ya encore il ya d'autres choses
à faire il ya il ya une vie après la
présidence
justement on va parler de cette vie là
ça va être ma dernière question sans
parler de politique puisqu'on a un
week-end électoral
certains vous prédisent une carrière
politique pour la suite pas forcément
tout de suite mais pour les années à
venir c'est des rumeurs ça a du sens
quand même pour vous vous y pensez ou
alors c'est complètement faux je connais
l'expression qui dit on ne prête qu'aux
riches aux riches en temps aux riches
d'expériences aux riches de ne pas
forcément d'autres termes sur le plan
monétaire
non ce ne sont que des rumeurs moi je
j'ai envie d'une vie publique on
assimile souvent la vie publique à la
vie politique
moi c'est l'associatif qui m'intéresse
le plus après je ne faut jamais dire
jamais on revient dessus et merci au
staff à larbaoui d'être venu en plate on
vous souhaite du coup le meilleur pour
pour la cifit merci à vous encore tout
de suite on passe à l'actualité de la
semaine
une actualité marquée par les révisions
du bac les premières épreuves se
déroulent la semaine prochaine c'est
donc la dernière ligne droite pour
réviser et hissé le cas par exemple de
péril une étudiante de villepreux qui
passe un bac pro esthétique nous l'avons
suivi dans ses révisions un reportage de
nicolas landry et camille lambert
histoire français ou management cinq
épreuves attendent perrine plus qu'une
semaine pour réviser avant de passer son
bac pro esthétique et même si cela ne
fait que quelques jours qu'elle a
commencé le planning est déjà chargé
j'ai révisé un petit peu le matin
forcément une matière une première
matière une matière dont j'ai pas moins
besoin de réviser comme l'histoire géo
je suis plus tôt à l'aise donc ça va et
après l'après midi j'ai surtout bossé
les grosses épreuves celle de par
exemple d'esthétique et celle de vente
où je fais c'est un peu plus difficile
du coup j'ai plus beau c'est celle ci
l'après-midi le stress commence à monter
j'avoue mais ça va d'après je sais que
je j'ai révisé tout au long de l'année
mais cours donc je me dis que ça ça va
vous êtes elle est très très stressée à
là ça va mais on je pense que cinq jours
avant d'invoquer plutôt que ça va monter
petit à petit est en fait la veille
faudra pas lui adresser la parole
un stress que perrine arrive quand même
à maîtriser sa méthode accompagner ces
révisions de musique ou d'une série faut
bien m'occuper en même temps enfin je
préfère faire plusieurs choses en même
temps parce que sinon je suis pas motivé
pour fermer les fissures fait voilà ça
me permet de me motiver mais de la
musique je fais des fiches tout
simplement
après moi je sais que je relis aussi
beaucoup mes cours les définitions
surtout les mots importants
après si une phrase qui me paraît très
importante je vais l'a marqué mais après
c'est pour la sauce des abréviations
voilà c'est les choses les plus
importantes soit certain de l'exacte
m'en faire un court parce que chien ça
c'est rien de le recopier comme près de
700 mille candidats en france perrine
est attendu jeudi 15 juin pour la
première épreuve c'est la première fois
qu'elle passe cet examen
et elle espère bien la dernière la
finale départementale de robotique c'est
lundi les dix établissements
sélectionnés choisissent actuellement
les équipes qui porteront leurs couleurs
direction le collège romain rolland de
sartrouville qui effectue une
compétition interne pour choisir son
champion un reportage de maxime le maine
pour le département des yvelines quel
robot représentera le collège romain
rolland de sartrouville à la grande
finale du concours robotique initiée par
le conseil départemental
c'est ce que doit définir aujourd'hui ce
jury déjà impressionné par le circuit
reflet de l'implication des élèves comme
l'expliquent mathieu lemaitre étudiants
alice ti qui les a épaulé tout au long
du projet ils ont vraiment su développer
quelque chose autour de la ville du
futur qui était le sujet principal
on sent qu'ils y ont mis leur coeur leur
motivation et leur vécu tous les jours
pour en arriver là les élèves on aime
travailler en dehors du temps scolaire
une fierté pour le proviseur c'était pas
un projet qui était facile au départ
c'est des élèves qui sont très impulsifs
mais qui ont démontré leur capacité de
travail en équipe de faire des
concessions de faire des choix et de les
assumer jusqu'au bout
savoir assumer une valeur importante
souligné à plusieurs reprises par le
jury notamment lors du passage de cette
équipe venue sans robot on n'a pas eu de
repos à cause d'un élève qui a voulu
changer les
et capteurs mais il n'a pas eu le temps
de les replacer pendant plus d'une heure
chacune des quatre équipes tentent de
convaincre le jury sont évidemment
évaluer les performances du robot mais
également la présentation orale s'est
assez bien passé on a essayé de faire
comme on pouvait malgré cette un petit
peu de stress c'était bien mais sauf que
le robot n'a pas pu compléter leur gamme
et que la programmation soit parfaite
la présenter devant le proviseur le
verdict tombe c'est l'équipe futur x qui
représentera l'établissement ça s'est
bien passé on
il ya une très bonne équipe on sait tous
répartis les tâches y avait une bonne
entente entre la cen-sad désormais
soutenu par les autres équipes futur x
se doit peaufiner son robot pour
affronter ceux des neuf autres collèges
qui participeront à la grande finale le
12 juin plus de 70 mètres de long une
dizaine d'éléments un ensemble en béton
le nouveau skatepark de maurepas été
inauguré il ya quelques jours située au
stade du bois il accueillera des riders
mort passe bien mais aussi des villes
voisines mais le nip ok ils sont à
l'origine du projet les jeunes de
maurepas ont rêvé d'un nouveau style
parc
il a été inauguré vendredi de juin
dernier l'ancien était très vieillissant
et même dangereux ce que j'ai du le le
faire fermer puisqu'il avait des plaques
métalliques qui se soulever et donc
après ça a été soumis au vote des morts
passe bien et plus de 200 votes se sont
prononcés sur ce projet et donc voilà
après on a engagé d un groupe de travail
que j'ai souhaité participatif proposé
lors d'un projet participatif et d'un
budget de moins de cent mille euros
la structure est en béton un matériau
pérenne une piste de 72 mètres de long
une dizaine d'éléments pour rider fait
longtemps qu'on attend ça et puis c'est
au rendez vous ça ça glisse bien ça
roule bien
mais a tout ce qu'il faut on est content
c'est par attendu depuis des années du
béton ce que tu vois le mouton qu'on a
là bas c'est pas tip top
donc c'est cool qui en investissement
pour pour le skate park dès son
inauguration le skate park était pris
d'assaut le maire lui-même n'a pas pu
résister après les routes l'archéologie
autour du tourisme le rapprochement se
poursuit entre les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine les élus
des deux assemblées étaient réunies il y
a quelques jours au conseil
d'administration pour réfléchir à un
développement mutuel du secteur les
précisions avec ce reportage de nicolas
d'andré l'île de france a attiré 46,7
millions de touristes en 2015 un secteur
majeur dans le cadre du rapprochement
entre les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
et cela à travers une politique commune
sur la stratégie du développement du
tourisme des deux territoires
on a défini huit axes de travail qui
sont pas les rappeler les huit mais il
ya ce que je veux dire le tourisme rural
le tourisme d'affaires le tourisme
hôteliers le tourisme patrimonial et
c'est le tourisme de la scène huit
priorités choisies après un travail
lancé en septembre dernier les membres
de la commission tourisme de le pays
yvelines hauts de seine ont rencontré
près de 150 professionnels du tourisme
pour connaître leurs attentes
le première au betis était déjà de faire
un diagnostic de je dirais de la
complémentarité qu'il peut y avoir entre
le 78 92 avec versailles avec bien sûr
notre axe seine qui est quelque chose de
fondamental
et puis du côté du 92 également avec la
défense qui est un lieu aussi d'un
développement touristique d'affaires qui
est fondamental est important avec ses
deux pôles touristiques les deux
collectivités partagent aussi la scène
un site stratégique pour développer des
activités pour les visiteurs nationaux
et internationaux avec en ligne de mire
le développement économique
ce potentiel simplement il doit être mis
en cohérence avoir une politique
d'ensemble pour le promouvoir
on voit bien que paris est saturé
d'ailleurs et donc
il ya vraiment un champ là qui est tout
à fait important producteur aussi
d'emplois et de croissance
il est normal que l'ouest parisien
cherche à récupérer à capitaliser sur
cette richesse cette stratégie
interdépartementale et portait sur
quatre ans entre 2017 et 2021
un point d'étape sur cette politique
sera effectué lors d'une assemblée en
2019 et on referme cette émission du
côté de versailles où des élèves de 6e
ont écrit et mise en scène des
spectacles autour d'une thématique les
déchets le projet intitulé à trier ses
jouets est initié par la communauté
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
le metteur en scène éric bouvron
l'accompagnant l accompagner bach foot
et le mois molière regarder une fable de
la fontaine les tournées c'est le fil
conducteur de leur spectacle ces élèves
de 6e du collège raymond poincaré
participe à trier ses jouets un projet
pédagogique c'est de faire réfléchir et
faire s'exprimer les enfants à propos du
recyclage de l'environnement général
mais là plus axé sur le recyclage et les
déchets et qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
déchets à travers une approche ludique
et artistique où ils vont pouvoir
s'exprimer en créant en écrivant
composeront
imaginons des danses et
des textes tout ce qu'ils veulent
accompagnés de leur professeur de
français d'un intervenant
ils créent leur histoire de a à z chacun
ramener un peu de sa paume et et bas à
la fronde a tout mélangé et ça fait
quelque chose d'assez d'assez bien avec
le prof et c'est même c'est le projet de
base c'est quand même dont de s'amuser
tout ça c'est quand même un vrai
problème pour l'humanité
le problème de la pollution du gâchis et
tout ça
leur spectacle c'est le résultat de six
séances d'une heure et demie de travail
et elle est sûre de moi une
représentation unique est prévue durant
le mois molière c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo merci de nous avoir suivis
retrouver tous nos reportages au replay
sur tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fils n'oubliez pas
d'aller voter
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]